a storm is brewing
in south dakota
[Music]
it's moving swiftly into minnesota
[Music]
a mass exodus is taking place from one
social media website
to another but there's still some
survivors left behind
album shares party pictures
this one doesn't look any different
the user is sent to a web page and it's
disguised in a coat
that makes it look normal but the last
two letters
reveal its true identity they're
prompted to install a video player
update
[Music]
this unsuspecting computer is now
a zombie connected to a mesh of other
half-dead machines spread
all throughout the planet a botnet
known simply as
you are watching disrupt tv
congratulations you won congratulations
an antivirus company announces a
discovery
typically urls are hosted on a single
web server
through a single internet protocol
address
if one is found to be malicious it's
fairly easy to chop it down from the
root
by blocking the ip but these urls
are utilizing a tactic known
as fast flux in a fastflux network the
ip address of the domain name is
constantly switched out
making it near impossible to find the
core of the infection
perfect for the first stage of
self-propagation over the dates
in this time period we see variants
appearing that are created from the
original myspace exploit
target skype targets twitter
makes its way onto the macintosh
ecosystem
it spreads not only through social media
messages
but right under our noses an ordinary
website
you can download files from here coop
face covers the otherwise safe download
button
with an html iframe this sends a pdf
file to the user
that when opened scans the computer
it's searching for a file transfer
protocol if found
it will send out a message to the other
bots who will subsequently use the
exploited username
and password to make a new home within
its victim
with each newly infected host the botnet
grows larger
creating a decentralized untraceable
network
that turns left turns right
goes up and goes down on the whim
of whoever has the steering wheel
how to protect your computer dave yeah
ron it's really scary how easily it can
infect your computer in fact we have
computer experts show us
it's 1997 and the most popular website
in the world is
more than 17 million people use the site
every month
to explore a new frontier known
as the internet but at 7pm
on monday december 8th yahoo
is hijacked
confronts anyone who opens the browser
the message reveals that the computer of
every single person who's visited yahoo
in the past month has been infected with
a worm
and on christmas day in less than three
weeks
the bomb will detonate and destroy
millions of contaminated computer
systems
that is unless the hijacker's one demand
is met anger erupts
and over the following days protests
break out on the streets across the
united states
they set up camp outside federal
courthouses and from new york
to california people call into radio
stations to cry out the phrase
in real life and in video games anything
else to say
yeah free kevin um it's now just one
week until christmas
and most are asking
he hoists himself up and looks through
the bars on his windows
[Music]
but kevin isn't a terrorist he isn't a
mafia boss and he's not here because he
wiretapped the nsa or blackmailed fbi
agents
authorities say he poses in even greater
danger
because with a single phone call they
say
he can dial into the no rad and access
the nuclear arsenal
of the united states of america the
event of nuclear weapons changed the
course of the world
kevin might only be an innocent
prankster or
kevin could be the world's most
dangerous cyber terrorist
a man who has north america at his
fingertips
to free or not to free
that is the question
[Music]
this is a windows registry key
and this is that same windows registry
key modified
by kubeface when a computer wants to
connect to a website
it goes through a domain management
system or
dns this is typically provided by an
internet service provider
a vpn circumvents this by building its
own bridge
that handles the traffic toward whatever
website the user types in
[Music]
coop face is doing something similar but
instead of directing traffic to the
website
in its true form it repaints road signs
changes gps directions and guides the
user
to wherever it pleases
youtube wikipedia paypal all resolve to
ip addresses
employed by the command and control
center
this is how the kube makes its money
there when that user clicked the link
kubeface
instantly shot his browser through a
number of affiliate advertising networks
instead of the machine sending http get
to google
as it normally does an infected machine
sends
http git to coop face who responds with
a list of affiliated links
it's only after receiving those links
the machine correctly sends
http get to google who then returns
with the legit results the first result
corresponds to the first affiliate link
and when clicked for just a brief moment
in advertisement
after that process the used affiliate
link is scrubbed
and a new one takes its place these
systems may offer two bucks per
thousand users that click the affiliate
link multiply that by hundreds of
thousands of infected bots across the
planet
clicking links all day and at this point
coupe faces command and control center
is passively pulling in
[Music]
the victim may now notice that something
feels off
their loading times are slower toolbars
keep appearing out of nowhere
and just in time a helping hand
is offered similar to the google search
a response is sent to kube's command and
control center
it responds with a list of anti-virus
software downloads
pix1 and displays it on the desktop
after the user pays
[Music]
their pc remains infected and command
and control
gets a paycheck
we live in a world of bots
but where do these soulless beings come
from
alan turing a 20th century mathematician
creates the turing test in the
experiment
a human has a text-based conversation
with a computer
and another human if he can't tell who
is the computer
and who is the human then the computer
has passed the test
now we've flipped this instead of us
the human telling computers apart from
humans
computer needs to figure out who's you
and who's me
and who is its robotic kin
so you are a robot no my name is
cleverbot
yes you are a robot and your name is
clever i am a robot
yes i know together we are robots
i'm not a robot i'm a unicorn
in the beginning coop face uses a small
portion
of manually created accounts to spread
initially
but now as the infrastructure grows
it needs a way to create thousands of
fake accounts to ensnarl thousands of
more victims
completely automated public turing test
to tell computers and humans apart
normally capture would be a brick wall
for an amateur bot program
but coop face has found a clever
workaround
first it sends the following command to
facebook
the login and password are encoded via
an encrypted scheme
that involves reading the letters their
corresponding ac values
and comparing that to a successive
string of numbers from 0 to 1
to two to three to four to encrypted
becomes unencrypted new account
information is sent to the social media
site
the social media site responds with
another packet containing a blank bio
birthday favorite books activities
kube autofills this with randomly
generated info
that feels just realistic enough
next the site will ask for captcha to
circumvent this
the captcha puzzle is mirrored to the
desktop of any individual
in its bot army
two things happen their screen is
unlocked
and the captcha for the new minion is
complete
coop face deploys this scheme a number
of times
millions of friend requests are sent
across facebook and the army
grows ever larger
cyber investigators uncover an
irregularity
the connection of interest is located on
servers hosted
by coriacs in the uk
the data flowing in and out of one of
these servers matches
observed data by coupe face
the command and control centers are
wiped out and the bots are left
wandering
without direction
hundreds of new commanding control
centers appear which ushers in coop
faces peak
with an estimated infected machines
the unraveling of coop face is delivered
through the very same websites
it previously exploited an apache http
client
is used to control files to and from
a web server for the most part it can be
functioned anonymously
unless a specific option is left
untouched
this option will drop breadcrumbs that
display to any visitor
what type of files are being transferred
to and from the botnet
on the daily
[Music]
this photo's metadata shows it was taken
with an iphone
on september 15 2009
this is a daily backup of the coop face
command and control software
inside an ip stands out
this is programmed to automatically send
a daily sms
update to five numbers updates that show
exactly how much profit
the network is pulling in the numbers
are searched
one is found an online marketplace for
vehicle sales
license plate in full view another
market
selling sphinx's a name
is registered on a number of websites
the same bmw is found on flickr also the
cat
[Music]
one of the found email addresses on a
social media page points to a corporate
email
called mobsoft the website is defunct
but the company details list in anton
k job listings the numbers on it
both match the php found in coop
[Music]
their names are cross-referenced with
their respective social media accounts
and here they posted their vacation
pictures
publicly facebook docs as their full
names and pictures
they are dubbed alibaba and four
and now in a rather anti-climactic peak
the coop face command and control
centers simply go
offline
from that point on to our current day
and age
kubeface's original command and control
center has never been reactivated
alibaba and four are off the grid
and the zombie army
remains dormant
[Laughter]
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
good evening citizens of the metaverse
and welcome to the electronic simulation
showcase
show today we're looking at the sports
car of at home virtual reality hardware
the roto chair this gaming chair is
specially designed to increase immersion
in your favorite vr simulations
plug in your hmd cables into the grade a
cable management system
when you turn your head in game the
motorized chair will turn your entire
body
a full 360 degrees the roto is equipped
with double rumble motors on the bottom
and back sides
meaning every explosion every windstar
will
feel like you're actually there intense
is the name of the game when you're
kicking back and watching a film
flying through the vast cosmos or
shooting your way to victory
with full padding it's like you're
sitting on an immersive cloud
ready to reach the depths of the
metaphysical simulational virtual
virtual invertebrate virtual trends
configuration
the roto chair the world's first
interactive vr chair
[Music]
[Music]
i joined a bunch of phone freakers who
are gathering for a party
something like two dozen people show up
each one almost as much of a nerd as the
worst of a ham radio enthusiast
the conversation inevitably gets around
to one of my favorite targets
cosmos the pacific telephone mission
system that could bestow
so much power on any freaker who could
access it
[Music]
as we started talking i realized the
building that houses cosmos is nearby
[Music]
the guard is a young guy i say hey
how you doing we're out late i work here
i wanted to show my friends where i work
he says sure just sign in doesn't even
ask for an id
smooth
we've been calling departments and
analyzing phone company operations for
so long
that we know exactly where the cosmos
employees work
room 108
a folder on the wall holds up sheets of
paper listing dial-up numbers for every
wire center in southern california
armed with this list and login
credentials i'd have the ability to
control any phone line in pacific
telephone southern california service
area
hello i can't believe our luck we should
have left then
but i spot a set of cosmos manuals and
the temptation is irresistible
i tell the guys let's take the manuals
to a copy shop run off a copy for each
of us
then return the manuals before people
start coming back to work in the morning
it was the most stupid decision of my
early life
we drive around looking for a coffee
shop but can't find one it's
2 am so i take the manuals home with me
but i have a bad feeling about them so i
throw it all in some trash bags and give
them to my accomplice
tell them to throw him away or something
an unknown teenager has hacked a new
network
known as no norad it's an organization
that provides aerospace warning and
protection for north america
and this kid infiltrated the system just
to have a look around
the move is so bold that it inspires the
film war games
a game or is it real journalist john
markov gets in touch with kevin
he wants him to be part of his new book
on hackers named
cyberpunk he's gained a reputation as
master of social engineering it's the
art of deceiving people
into sharing valuable and confidential
information for fraudulent purposes
but he's not interested in the money on
offer he wants to maintain a low profile
so
he refuses to be part of the book much
to the displeasure
of john markov
on a hot summer's day in l.a kevin pulls
out of the stephen s
wise temple where he works as a
receptionist
in his rear view mirror he thinks he
sees a group of three men following him
in a ford crown victoria he builds a
u-turn
and sure enough they do the same
kevin speeds down the i-405 and the car
races after him
suddenly one of the men places a cop car
flasher on the roof of the car
and now the sirens are crying out kevin
pulls over the officers rush up
they scream kevin is dragged out
handcuffed
his car is ransacked but there's no
signs of any bomb you're not gonna find
him
he's hauled to the station the officers
don't find a logic bomb but
they know about a crime kevin committed
a friend told the police everything he's
sentenced
12 months in prison followed by three
years of supervised release
[Music]
he sits in the courtroom betrayed and
alone
[Music]
his attorneys plead with a judge that
his hacking is an addiction
rather than criminal behavior they say
the young man needs help
not a prison cell kevin rises and pleads
his case to the judge
by now he's a veteran in deception
the judge agrees in order that kevin
served a sentence in a halfway house
for those with compulsive disorders
kevin laughs as he's listening to the
ruling
he was arrested for tricking his way
into computer system and now he deceives
the judge into thinking that
he's the victim of his own crimes
it's a few weeks until supervised
release ends
and the demon on his shoulder is
whispering
he starts learning about pacific bell a
telephone company based in california
an idea appears if he gets caught he'll
be sent
to jail but if he doesn't then he'd have
fooled the authorities
right under their noses soon he has all
the passwords and credentials he needs
to take control of the company's
voicemails kevin is on the run for two
years
he loses a hundred pounds when he learns
that how a criminal walks is the number
one way they're recognized
he puts pebbles in his shoes to change
his stride
he uses over a dozen different names his
favorite
is eric wise
he begins a crime spree that infiltrates
the world's biggest companies nokia
kevin sips his coffee as he reads the
paper suddenly
a chill passes down his spine fbi agents
take their positions outside the house
in california
they see their target sitting inside
burst in and draw their weapons and the
man denies that he's kevin mitnick
he's a middle eastern immigrant doesn't
even own a computer
more than 2 000 kilometers away in
seattle kevin throws his paper to the
ground
his name emblazoned on the front page of
the new york times
kevin is adamant the stories in the
articles are lies
he never hacked in a norad or wiretapped
the nsa
but if you believe kevin
then you shouldn't trust anything you've
heard so far
about kevin he takes on mythical status
overnight
a little-known prankster is now public
enemy number one
of cyberspace kevin walks the streets of
seattle in a daze
many of the passing faces on the
sidewalk seem to be staring straight
back at him
he hears the faint sound of a helicopter
in the sky
feels his heart beginning to thump no
one seems to notice the helicopter but
they do notice
kevin he hurries into the courtyard of
an apartment complex and uses the tall
trees as cover
peering through the leaves
kevin tosses a package into the bushes
and bursts into a full-on sprint
he gets away but from what
one of america's top cyber security
experts is finalizing plans to leave for
a ski vacation the next day
and suddenly his own computer is hacked
his phone rings your security technique
will be defeated your technique is no
good
to someone like him the attack and
subsequent taunts
are an act of war
he sets up a series of stealth
monitoring posts and creates his own
software to track the hacker
he waits in silence until
the alarm is triggered he traces the
intruder to a computer modem
connected to a cellular telephone
somewhere
on the east coast
[Music]
a man steps out onto his balcony in
raleigh north carolina
and suddenly a chill passes down his
spine
the fbi agents take their positions
outside the house
they see their target sitting inside
journalist john markoff watches from the
street
the agents burst in and draw their
weapons
but find nothing the man furiously
denies that he's kevin mitnick
he's so convincing the fbi agents are
about to leave
[Music]
but then an agent notices an old ski
jacket in the cupboard
he empties the pockets and out falls
a paste up legacy media pitches up their
circus tents outside
most wanted computer hacker is behind
bars kevin shares one large holding cell
with 60 other inmates
he doesn't need for two days because the
food isn't kosher
inside all eyes are fixed on the
defendant
kevin is charged with 14 counts of wire
fraud 8 counts of possession of
unauthorized access devices
interception of wire or electronic
communications
and causing damage to a computer when
kevin is led away from the court
tsutomu calls out from the front row
kevin looks back at his nemesis the one
man who finally saw through the lies and
deceptions
to find him he nods
says nothing and walks away
his appeals for bail are churned down by
every single court in the u.s
including the supreme kevin says the
beefed-up charges are an
injustice and his treatment is a denial
of his constitutional rights
but why won't anyone believe him
[Music]
he has one last idea
but then a group of officers storm into
the cell
and throw them into solitary confinement
it might change a lot of things in a
negative way i mean he's trying so hard
to get
at least get a trial and then this comes
[Music]
up
christmas day passes
without incident the hack on yahoo was a
hoax carried out by members of the free
kevin movement
there was no logic bomb
after four years of prison and solitary
confinement
kevin pleads guilty to four counts of
wire fraud two counts of computer fraud
and one count of illegally intercepting
wire communication
i didn't think of the consequences when
i was engaging in this behavior i just
did it
i'd copy the code store it on a computer
and go right on to the next without even
reading the code
interesting you know and that could be a
complete different motivation of
somebody
who's really out for financial gain or
foreign
country or a competitor trying to obtain
you know
information like you know like economic
espionage
you know i hate to suggest the waste of
your talent but as i listen to you i
think you'd make a great lawyer
[Music]
well i i don't know if you're convicted
of a felony if they'd allow you to be
admitted to the bar
kevin mitnick is released from prison
after nearly five years
when kevin was on his crime spree his
hacking exploits seemed like mythology
to the outside world but by the time the
sun hits his face
the world needs his skills
so soon after his release he testifies
before the senate
and advises on how to better protect
computer systems from attacks
[Music]
so i really like sleep and the thing
that i do like about sleep is that it's
an alternate reality
nothing is impossible in sleep
when you dream you can fly and you can
also
die you can laugh and you can cry
you can sing but you won't notice a
thing
because you're asleep i feel like
sleep is a transportation to a new world
for eight or less hours or maybe even
more
so uh sleep is very nice
to have i feel like it's a privilege
because some other people they don't
have the access to sleep because of
things like insomnia so
i feel like you should never take sleep
for granted because if you stay up
i think you're going to stay up for a
long time so
sleep is very good for the body and
it's awesome